strongly urging this wonderful book on
all of you the white tiger how many of
you read this thing one well did you
like it yeah it's better than better
than dickens at looking through a system
from the bottom up and making it
entirely real so I strongly urge that on
you and once you pick it up you'll read
it in a one long session need a little
leisure for that but not a lot the most
note the simplest thing to say about
globalization and the poor is that it
has if you think about poverty in
absolute terms it has alleviated a lot
of poverty if you think about it in
relative terms it has made a lot of
people who would not have thought of
themselves as poor in eighteen forty or
eighteen eighty or nineteen twenty think
of themselves as poor now because of
what's going on around them the volcanic
eruption of wealth around the globe now
I should also note there that there's a
coercive element to economic growth
miroslav referred to it very briefly but
even when there's no kind of obvious
Tara native the thing the
marginalization of once once
remunerative and valid ways of making a
living what happens to the ten hecht our
farm in once the scale economies of
global commodity production set in is
that it's marginalized it is forced out
and skills which were once valuable
become less valuable so there's all that
going on but let's do this is again hans
Rosling wonder
full data animation I hope I can have
real trouble with this mouse is way too
active for me here we go we're in 1840
here the vertical dimension is life
expectancy the horizontal dimension is
income per capita and the scale on on
both is linear so we're not log scaling
makes it makes it pretty tough to
interpret change and so now we're going
to play the movie for about a hundred
and seventy years each dot is a country
they're color coded by the map up here
the diameter of the dot represents
population and watch what's happening
let's see if we can stop there for a
second ok so far what's happened mostly
life expectancy has gone up sharply and
at dramatically different rates right
it's mostly going up in western and and
North American settings it's going up
very fast and in the background not
shown here the birth rate is not going
down so as as life expectancy goes up
death rates go down birth rates don't go
down we're creating the population surge
which brings us nearly 27 billion people
today
china is the big red balloon okay so so
what's good what what what's the story
the story is life expectancy changing
and then wealth increasing for at
dramatic rates for about half the globe
what's hidden in this is that take take
India the the large blue bubble is that
in India the vertical scale of
inequality is going up fast fast fast
and the white tiger is that story I'm
going to stop there and it's I think it
is it I think its ambassador halls turn
am i right